what does wealth look like to you is it
$100 a thousand dollars a million
dollars we can always go higher but how
much is too much in today's world the
richest 1% of the population owns almost
half of the world's wealth does that
seem right to you will let's level the
playing field and see what we get this
is what if and here's what would happen
if money was distributed equally
according to forbes business magazine
the top ten richest people in the world
own a combined seven hundred and forty
five billion in wealth that's more than
most countries producing goods and
services every year after the 2008
financial crisis and the Occupy Wall
Street movement you're probably aware
that wealth distribution in the world is
well and studies show that the divide is
only getting bigger but what if we took
all the world's cash investments assets
etc sold them and gave every person in
the world an equal share would we be a
healthier happier society we can wage a
war on poverty but can humans win
against greed if you liquidated all of
the world's productive assets and
combine them with all the money in the
global economy you'd be looking at a
huge pile of cash roughly two hundred
and fifty trillion US dollars in fact
that's so much money that if you stack
that 250 trillion in $100 bills it would
stretch more than halfway to the moon
but how far would this money gets you
and everyone else in the world if it was
divided equally well take 250 trillion
and divide it between the current world
population of seven point seven billion
and everyone is worth about thirty two
thousand five hundred dollars
feeling shortchanged don't roughly 75%
of the world's population lives on less
than that every year the equal
distribution of the world's wealth would
certainly give a lot of people a
much-needed leg up those living in
extreme poverty and lower-income
households could afford more food water
clothing shelter and other necessities
that some of us take for granted
but how long would those opportunities
last in a world of seven point seven
billion people who are motivated by
different things and who have different
skill sets
maybe not long at all the first big
hurdle would be financial education in
order to keep relative wealth equality
people would have to be smart with their
money now that doesn't mean cut out all
entertainment and stick to the bare
necessities but don't do this we also
have to wonder what would happen to the
quality of goods and services in a world
where everyone makes the same and
there's no incentive to innovate or work
harder without strict regulations you
can imagine how this egalitarian society
could revert to one very much like our
own the world is full of entrepreneurs
people who are looking to make a buck or
simply want to make a positive
contribution to society you can see how
these people might invest their share of
the world's loot into new ideas they
could convince others that the product
of their ideas is worth paying for and
if enough people buy into it once again
the market will give rise to
millionaires billionaires and huge
corporations in short some people will
use their share to become very rich
while others may fall back into poverty
due to a lack of education or unforeseen
circumstances like an illness or a
natural disaster but despite the
resurgence of an economic divide there's
still hope in this scenario universal
basic income projects have been tested
around the world - generally favourable
results while some studies revealed that
when guaranteed a lump sum of money
every year work effort decreased they
also showed that universal basic income
increased school attendance reduced
medical costs in mental health cases
was not squandered on luxury goods
Universal basic income isn't a new idea
but we're still learning how to make it
work effectively naturally a perfect
world where everyone has the same amount
of money isn't feasible but that doesn't
mean we can't ensure everyone gets
enough food water clothing and shelter
if you want more than that you're gonna
have to work for it learn how to be
smart with your money manage it well
live within your means and keep an eye
out for good opportunities are you
waiting for that billion-dollar idea to
pop into your head it won't come on its
own but it might help if you start
asking yourself why deaf